مراسل الجزيره محمد الطيب الذي يلتقي احدى
العائلات السودانيه محمد نبدا معك خاصه مع
تجدد الاشتباكات في جنوب الخرطوم كيف
ينعكس ذلك على حياه المواطنين والعائلات
فعلا للاشتباكات متجدده في عدد من المناطق
في جنوبها الخرطوم بعد صلاه العيد وقبلها
كذلك نحن الان مع احدى الاسره هنا في
منطقه المعموره تحدثنا لديهما انهم كيف
استقبلوا هذا العيد كانت الاجابه ان هذا
العيد منقوص الاركان ليست الفرحه فيه كما
كانت في العاده السابقه مشاكل متعلقه
بالتجهيز للعيد مشاكل متعلقه بلم الشمل
والتحرك من منطقه الى اخرى معنا الان فواز
وهو رب هذه الاسره
ونستطلع معه كيف كان عيدكم السلام عليكم
العيد في السنه مختلف جدا جدا من السنين
السابقه يعني اشتباكات ضرب نار تفاصيل كده
كثيره امني مختل جدا جدا في السودان فمعظم
الاسر في منطقه المعموره هنا او في الجريف
في سافرت للاغاليم تركت الخار
عدد سكان بيجي بسيط جدا جدا الايات كان
معايدات في العيد بعد المصلين بعد الصلاه
نخش البيوت نصلي نسلم على الناس في البيت
فالحياه دي قلدت في السنه دي
في بعض الاوضاع الامنيه دي شويه كده العيد
مختلف جدا جدا الحمد لله رب العالمين ربنا
يصلح الحال بتاعت البلاد ويرجع لم يرجع
وترجع الاعياد تاني للسودان ان شاء الله
نتمنى ذلك
ربت اسره
لهذا العيد نكهه خاصه عاده ما تقدمون
البسكويت والمخبوزات التي تعمل العيد هذه
المره لا نرى سوى التمر وبعض من الحلويات
ما الذي حصل حتى التمر ده بعد باقي
الرمضان يعني ما طارعنا السوق ما مشينا
حتى ما قدرنا نطلع نعمل حاجه
لانه الضرب ده كان يعني قبل العيد بكم يوم
كذا كان الناس واحد نفسه 25 رمضان يمشي
يجهز حاله يكسر عياله ويجيب الحاجات
الناقصه في البيت عشان يجهز للعيد فرحه
العيد لكن الحمد لله قدر الله ما شاء فعل
وهذا احنا قعدنا يعني وقعدنا بالحاجه اللي
عندنا في البيت المهم قاعدين حتى البقالات
قفلت حتى ما قادر تجيب
موادار المهم اللي عنده في البيت هسا
بياكل من باقي بيتهم ما عندي في البيت
الجيران ما شاء الله بنمشي لبعض بنشيل من
بعض بناكل مع بعض لكن برضو العيد يعني
العيد زمان فيه والفرحه وفي الجيران يعني
اغلبيتها في وسط مشمر نسافر يعني هسه
بيقول له اربعه بيوت بتلقى في بيت واحد
الناس اللي قاعدين يعني كلهم سافروا ما في
شيء حتى العدديه المعايده في الحين قليله
يعني ما زي زمان
يعني اطفالكم
باعتبارك يعني رب اسره كيف كان العيد
بالنسبه لهم وماذا تفعلون اذا استمر هذا
الوضع على ما هو عليه ما هو المخطط
والله العيد للاطفال شويه سيء جدا او صعبه
وقاسي وبالناس الكبار هو لهم قاسي لكن
الصغار طبعا متعودين انهم يلعبوا في
الشوارع
والتفاصيل العيد بعد الاطفال الكسوه بتاعت
العيد ملابس العيد الحلويات حقت العيد
العاب العيد دي كلها تماما ما في طفل
حاليا في شارع برا بيلعب او عنده حاجه
يعني نحن صراحه والله الوضع اصبح قاسي جدا
جدا بالنسبه للاطفال بالنسبه للناس الكبار
ربنا يصلح الحال
يعني اذا استمرت هذا الوضع على ما هو عليه
في ظل نقص وشحف الامكانيات مواد الغذاء ما
المخطط ما الذي ستفعلونه والله بصراحه ما
في يدنا اي حاجه نعملها لانه صراحه كل
الدكاكين مغلقه كل الاسواق مغلقه كل
المحلات التجاريه مغلقه البلد في حاله
ركود ما في اي شيء نقدر والله عندنا
مدخرات بسيطه من زمان رمضان موجوده في
المنزل اذا جفت او اذا انقطعت خلاص ما في
شيء في يدنا نعمله فنرفع الكريم سبحانه
وتعالى للمولى عز وجل انه يخفف علينا
البلاء ويبعد مننا هذا الشهر ان شاء الله
يا رب العالمين
سامي اكلمه اخيره
كيف
ستنظرون للمستقبل هل عندكم داخلكم امال ان
هذه ان هذه الحرب وهذا الاقتتال سينتهي
والامور ستعود الى مجاريها
ان شاء الله حيكون احسن من كل الاحسنه
يعني قدر ما نعل للحال اصعب بنقول ربنا
بيفرجها رب العالمين ونعاين نقول يمكن
بكره احسن واحسن لكن الوضع لو بقى اخطر من
كذا هذه زول عنده حاجه في بيته حسب ما
نفدت النسب هتطلع من الحته ما تقعد يعني
ما في ما في شيء يعني يعني الليله لو ما
الحرب قتلتك حيكون لك الجوع المرض ما في
صيدليه فاتحه ما في مستشفى فاتح والحمد
لله بس ننتظر فضل رب العالمين ربنا يفرجها
علينا من فوق ويوقف الحاله دي وقف الحريق
دا مع داوه بين
اذا ساميه لخصت الا من يعني يقتلك او
تقتلك الحرب فان الجوع والمرض والتعافي
واحده ايضا من الازمات الموجوده شوحه
الامكانيات عدد من المحال التجاريه مغلقه
بالاضافه الى المستشفيات
حوالي ثلثي المستشفيات في الخرطوم خرجت من
الخدمه وبالتالي اصبح الوضع يضيق شيئا
فشيئا فشيئا مع استمرار الاقتتال واستمرار
هذه الحرب في الخرطوم نعم محمد العيد بجزء
كبير منه للاطفال لا اعلم اذا كان من
الممكن ان نستمع الى احد الاطفال كيف يشعر
بالعيد في ظل هذه الظروف اذا توفر لك ذلك
نعم لدينا طفل معنا اتفضل يا شباب
اسمك منو
العيد ده بالنسبه لك كيف والله العيد
السنه ما زي كل سنه لانه السنه اللي فاتت
زي كل عيد بنكون فرحانين مؤهالينا وكده
لكن السنه دي بقدر اطلع من بيته عشان نحن
زايد واهلنا خايفين علينا
والله اصلا في البدايه كانت خوف لكن
يعني كذا
وامنياتك شنو في العيد ده حابين انها
تتحقق لك والله بتمنى انه البلد
وان شاء الله الله يصلح البلاد ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله هذه هي الامنيات ازدهار
الكل يتمنى ان تقف هذه الحرب مصطفى مثال
على ذلك في جميع الاسر كان هناك كثير من
الاطفال يخططون في هذا العيد عاده
سودانيون يلعبون ببعض الالعاب الاطفال
هناك العاب خاصه بهم يشترونها بحاله
التجاريه التجاريه مغلقه اللعب في الشوارع
وما الى ذلك من اشياء الامور تبدلت كل
الناس يحبونه يفضلون ان يكون في بيوتهم
ويخافون كذلك على اسره